trois défis comme ministre que mise en
vérité
d'hommes semblables rigaux
bonjour à tous vous écoutez ce couple
observateurs politiques je suis allée
jean bosco peur je vous souhaite la
bourdonnais sur ceux des futurs épisodes
de notre cellule autre vie politique aux
jeunes c'est le creusot les versements
syndicat seul professeur d'histoire
géographie et celui des arts et lettres
du peu de reconnaissance que l'on est en
france la montre je reçois pas qu'ils
puissent se poser le décor de cette
lettre
merci steam à 7 et
10 ans et robert
des étudiants
[Musique]
en histoire plutôt nation
je
dirais que je m'étais d'ailleurs c'était
magique de systèmes experts au fond
parce que
même si je m'appelle à l'élection
comme tout le monde et puis par la suite
je dirais que
c'était comme ça
et passer mais je dirais que c'est
surtout
la génomique sion qui était la femme sur
six est en tout cas de gauche et puis
celle de
la face
à
la suite d'élections et pas celle de
la langue salée
et puis il y avait aussi
une discussion
nationale il a succédé à son habitude a
pendant 18 ans pratiquement 1 giga store
on
présentation eux
que les états sont des outils utilisés
par les capitalistes qui sort de ses
intérêts
en 10 ans le prix international
est trompeuse et à la pêche
l'unification de classe nationale
qu'il faudrait attendre dépassé à l'état
et vinassan des percées revendiquées à
la fois d'un programme 100% communiste
et aussi
comment est ce que c'est possible c'est
ça l'idée
sortie nationale et populaire
93 une expression ne
cessa comment l'articuler
s'élança lénine qui justement
je dirais presque pas vraiment la
continuité mais même que jean jaurès il
montre qu'il y est fait ici et là bas
ils ne sont pas fait ma compatit
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas limité parce que
karl marx et friedrich engels
[Musique]
j'en profite pour signaler parce que
grâce
à ce manifeste où aller il est
effectivement écrit tu les perds ma
patrie le problème c'est que la suite et
c'est là parce que la suite mais face
qui n arrive c'est à dire que matériels
objectivement il
suffit de
disney pascoe
débat les vars coupable une
mondialisation comme une
organisation 4 pence donc l'idée c'est
que réclame la peine d'aller vers un mix
qui sonde extérieure
une force qui font
les chaque jour ensuite à une perte
immense merci bonifier les travailleurs
de la santé
son but j'ai envie d'y accoster
immédiate c'est à l'échelle la semaine
il est temps que j'assiste
très souvent
appelés à minimes c'est
aussi
ce fameux chose de qualité
semaine après soit était petit nation
qu'est ce que
c'est bien
ce qui n'est pas même commission voici
mes stations et max en culotte
et dans l'autre côté des femmes
souhaitent mais écrasé la souveraineté
populaire il se manifeste national c'est
clairement mais 592 sont des hommes
jeunes commencent même écraser la
naissance
[Musique]
de ce soir se ferment ils s'en sont
simplement de la commune de paris je
vous dis pas ça ici
[Musique]
c'est la souveraineté s'affirmer dans la
nation mais pas comme super espèce
d'entité fichiers
du magic mais ce n'est pas
seulement un outil qui
s'était excusé
idiot de
et c'est trop simple tout
simplement parce que
la batterie
est autiste et muet mais la paresse et
beaucoup de gars qui m'a dit si ces
gens la jeunesse
nationaliste
choix mais
j'assure
extérieurs
y compris des
civilisations se soit
[Musique]
cassé clavier et je dirais que si on n'a
pas cette
personne parce qu'il faut bien des
missions et
de la patrie c'est
très amusant c'est extrêmement
en fait dans la tradition mais
c'est clairement c'est l'association des
bleus qui sont abonnés
de toute façon
ces
cadres de la nation sénat
kg team
sebah
telles
que les migraines
aux
frontières si je vous le dire je sais
qu'il ya dix ans enfin il ya dix ans
michel
heureusement au beurre
et les jeunesses même respirer et dire
qu'il n'ya pas ce qui se passe mal avec
notre chance je dis ça parce que
justement le cas du ministre donc tu
l'aimés des échangeurs émissions
absolues des frontières
suisses ont
circulé s'ajoute une chose parce que
la question n'a pas de sens patrice mais
plus des noces ont
dénoncé la posture box contient
c'en est une personne
extrêmement
bas sur le
système d'exploitation
est limité aux
éditions
conditions
jeudi jusqu'à cinq sont les usages
être un outil ses frontières c'est très
utile par exemple si beau chic
dit que 50 ans n'est ce pas mr
l'offensive dès le premier simple le
camp des 218 et par conséquent les
matières sont utiles désisté la semaine
on
dira que ce que ces frontières
france oui vraiment à blâmer
pas une mobilisation à la cause
les frontières bien saviez comme
ailleurs
je veux dire de protection des biens
et
services comme
gmail à berne mi-janvier banier il s'est
engagé auprès des travailleurs sans
papiers
les gains découlant de la mythique
personnage est présente je m'appelle
aidé beaucoup le maire aux sans papiers
africains
d'afrique subsaharienne
et ça qui m'a dit vous savez
notre biologie vous retournez
on peut pas et est incluse dans des
canalisations merci
réalisation donc les frontières des
zooms elle ne sent pas à nous comparer
aux autres qu'il faut absolument passer
nous explique on sent quand même pas de
critiques que si sa fille
il faut s'appuyer dessus et si elles
servent du
smig et des
travailleurs sans papiers
pliés et massages ou c'est
avec une île au régime du capital sauf
que si les frontières signatures de
soutien
alors hier soir
ban il
faut plutôt le seul le show des bacs à
bouaké quatre candidats dont quatre
candidats et ensuite c'était pas envie a
démenti moment où chacun a parlé avec un
an thaï et de déficits et du coup aux
personnes qui appellent à voter soit une
scène sur la mention soit et de mieux
préciser la position
fait de mieux ça c'est sûr on a tous
les mêmes opérations que
je suis pas
réunies
at on indiqué que vous
tuez est aussi fière d'appuyer
sa démonstration des pratiques
contestables
qui
fâchent estation
investisseurs et la mine mon cher
monsieur que j'ai même parlé nature
multi
soit
en 2007
avait appelé à ce que font subir à
appuyer la candidature mélenchon de
manière critique d'accord ça voulait
dire que m
mais rien
[Musique]
ne nous sommes jamais la tête un
dispostif de la fasti miss parce qu'il y
avait des divergences et même des
divergences de l'époque était au premier
set mais fait que en 17 manches mais
aussi un très bon score grâce à une
femme mieux on la change dans la petite
et sa famille
depuis
et le basculement s'est fait au total de
18 et le printemps est là bas vu les
passants
souvent dégagé
je laisse à mon
sens soit pas qui était accusé le camp
national
et qui a fait du sommet à tous mais
aussi
ses couleurs mais ce n'est pas tout à
fait
tu m'as dit il a vu arriver
et koné est
en phase de sa vie
c'est à dire qu'aucun candidat à cette
élection dans ce même quel que soit ce
mythique d'apple sorti par exemple
une candidature en tant que psychiatre
album individuellement
[Musique]
c'est en effet un certain
steve mans soutien au candidat parce
qu'elle est on arrivé à sacrer occulter
les sujets
ces tensions sociales se financer
et oui l'argent
c'était vraiment conçu par cet objectif
aussi ambitieux
ambitieux en fait mais pousse le travail
et la station
c'est ce que lui même et chaque centime
de dieu
je rebondis sur ce que vous avez dit
hier
nicolas dupont aignan type et même si
donner idées dj console peser de
nouvelles visions dvd cd 2 ont décidé de
s'allier pour les élections pour un
programme de certitude est sorti de
l'auto
c'est pas en france fait ainsi les
six voitures s'est elle me les a pas
donc ça sur le compte
du reste nicolas du palois en allemand
ça que tu as un clip au
seigneur vous aimez premier ministre
lui dire que ce genre vous m'aviez
c'est si triste parce que
être sol et il faut reconnaître qu'il a
fait c'est bien sa lancée il
ya tout de
[Musique]
même de ces personnes ces concepts la
stratégie est
beaucoup plus sur la personne de
s'appliquer à soi
parce que ce qu'oublie de dire si
on le gagne on sait que presse mais
comme alexis
à l'université ou satie de l'eau en
outre
une bonne partie à tous mais une bonne
partie du patronat britannique était
sorti
c'est à dire que
le centre est
je suis dit station connaît la
liste artisans commerçants
mais aussi
celles là sont de classe même si on perd
cette immunité
mais cette
mesure la différence niveau de
protection sociale avec la france
la famille n'est pas le débat sur la
peine comme maîtresses grave expiration
dans une logique
ça s'est même pas du tout
mais l'essentiel
est acquis
facile bah oui il
expliqué que la leçon l'objectif c'était
d'en finir avec le modèle issu de gamme
avec le sommet
extraordinaire puisque sa naissance oui
qui d'ailleurs je lui ai dit mais sa
belle scène
savamment
sociaux la protection sociale
sa localisation
l'industrialisation
tout ça parce qu en fait réclamer la
satisfaction
une fille soit
on fait quoi
fectivement
justement ces maps est vierge si ce
qu'une étude
en temps fou ce serait un blocage
immédiat de capitaux blocage immédiat
les caps tout
juste m
c'est bon
il sait que le faut
l'argent fait les spurs ne
sont pas très social
et on se fait
marcel potentiellement soutiendrait une
liste aux législatives
du 13 juin la liste souverainiste qui se
fait avec des souverainistes de droite
et de gauche et d'ailleurs comme nous
allons savourer avec sa vue populaire
puisque peut-on s'imaginer en soutien
voire des personnes dans la liste si les
femmes subissent donc je pense notamment
bhp savons
pas sa génération fixité des chargeurs
oic d'allemand à cellou dalein
évidemment
café a franchi lipow imaginez vous
arriver tous ensemble à l'ouest aux
législatives qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que
j'appelle un chiffre est bon
on reste dans l'idéologie
en fait c'est pas propre aux logiques
synology doit suivre
le nom sympa dans une logique des
sources dans cette logique parce que
parce que
ça change
si le présent jacques mitsch
effectivement
vous avez vous échangé sujet libre
service divergence est bien souvent noté
le mur
ça parce que la vision du speg du
conseil
aussi c'est le dieu des partis
politiques les présents
alors c'est
ce que qu'il est même née parti
communiste est assis
alors d'içi est autrement dit lorsqu'il
avait il était très large
quel film polisse
une
cession
d'antalis
et puis
through the beach ou services âge
c'est
ce
qui donne un double imposition d'un
petit cadeau
parce que
justement le fric si
c'est risqué parce que s'il ne peut pas
se dit benji
guider le ca
2009 et visionnée fiction à la rupture
parce que c'est mon coeur du projet
communiste enfance
législatives si
ce serait avec des polices avec lesquels
des accords soient sentis
[Applaudissements]
même si son président aux critiques la
défense habituelle
la reconstruction des habitations
et puis surtout
éclatante militants et enfin la cgt au
ce et pcf
en pharmacie
france
il faut pas oublier que cette femme
avait aussi des gens qui commencent à
fléchir ils sont bénins et
glissements
on serait tous sens bien c'est ce mardi
avec le vrai coupable
alors
c'est mélenchon de cuisine au beach et à
questionner sur
sa
destinée comme banco
santander et si on obtient des scores au
premier tour
le traditionnel blanc a déserté la
gauche il est soit plus jeunes haute
tension où se réfugier chez national
et dès qu'ils s'adaptent être séduite
dans la gauche
comment expliquer cette situation
mais cette situation
j'ai super l'été je dirige à la louche
au parti socialiste
[Musique]
ils ont beaucoup d'émotion par bien avec
acronis le rassemblement
se sont déjà
à ce que
tu peux titane et patti smith que quand
je
jeudi la mémoire d'histoire
et
[Musique]
qui a saisi le haut
puisque la motion était
marxiste léniniste
jusqu'à tuer qu'il pesait très rapide
mais
des
chimistes ironie
si ces socialistes on nous parle ensuite
de la primaire ne fait pas de galles
reçoit
depuis un an sans
jamais dire que le schéma de
ces quatre ans sous la neige comme
ce qui s'est passé c'est que c'est ce
que dit mitterrand est peut-être encore
il face à un dîner
il a choisi c'est parce
qu'il suffit si ce n'est pas celle
justement donc actuelle nous depuis la
fonte sport
donc c'était même surprise mais depuis
85 ans et six mois après les personnels
dans la municipalité du mi6 par ceux là
mêmes années 80 le les populaires
oublier sa valise et sociaux
des
communes mon amie cathy où les sons sont
habitués à être mélangés car
c'est jacob c'est tout simplement parce
que ces agressions c'est la dmr douche
hammam et le projet
substituer qui s'appelle la bosnie
dont je soutenais woerth là quelques
mois
l'ast médias restent à réaliser une
vidéo politique comme celle extrêmement
parce que 2,6 à tous les instruments
nous sommes à
notre liste à
part
quelques petits pas
à partir à ce qu'on peut appeler la
souveraineté est bien là déjà fait à
avaler mais tout ceci est la face à
laloubère de fait avec mais ce n'est
pas tout et en fait même
heureuse ou gore violent
s'est passé mais j'assume ce choix qui
est fait d'abandon de la lutte
il est plongé dans l'orne qualifiant de
repenti queue de classement andré ciment
se dépêcher et malheureusement oui parce
que les
assises n'a jamais
ressenti de mort
extraits
cette fois c'est moi
avec ma bouche
c'est super
mais ma chance
ce cadre est
donc sage aux
mines m et tu n'as pas
une créature magique
[Musique]
donc si vous voulez cbs ben perso dans
cette année 170 buts
c'est beaucoup étudié beaucoup de
professeurs
[Musique]
à tout ça est juste mais
elle sera bien
[Musique]
entendu parler de l'asmo parce qu'il met
à insister beaucoup sur ce discours ou
pas ici de sauver les enfants
je dis pas qu'on
sache quand on sait que ces places
c'est ce populaire
jeu
qu'il faut baisse
mais si ça commence à nous mais bon on
perd il copiait travail
après l'occupation
je
sais maintenant choix s'est pas entraîné
il faut mettre
ces craignant qu'on avait fait vous
l'avez dit vous enseignez vous étudierez
les personnes sont
passées à l'espace et des cinq ans
maintenant
sauf qu'il n'a pas les hommes sur 100 et
fonda maintenant j'avais dit la
économique et sa conduite elle est
d'ailleurs il ya une
maintenance
c'est ce qui explique amazon et tu veux
s'il a
des projets
au sein de la série de lois et ses
aimables
comment dit on espère vous arrivez
devant les familles
des états unis timothy
c'est temporaire quand on n a pas les
prépas turrel bannières et les
conditions de vie matérielles
[Musique]
des casse cou mais ils se sont détournés
des jeunes quand même parce que ça
concerne une partie d'une pièce
[Musique]
quand
tu travailles
toutes les sections
liste est bien dans l'esprit de
combativité
des chasseurs expliqué que quand il y
avait une lutte sociale d'entreprise
c'est ce que pour valoriser quand il est
vif et là mais priez la place
une semaine sans
les femmes
je vais en profiter vous demander ce que
vous pensez des mouvements féministes et
actuel qui utilisent plutôt la question
du genre comme biologie des
substitutions à la classe et si l
opposition
radicale sur la question du patriarcat
bhl l'adoption des cultures en cuisine
mais
avant votre votre pied dessus ensuite
quelle mesure que le persil passion 17
août a donné que vous allez publier un
manifeste
la patiente en dessous
rcs présent partie mais
nous avons des commissions c'est
[Musique]
balisé dans votre
vision ou donner à modeste mais
sa frappe est
[Musique]
décidée par exemple
celle
de volley messieurs
csss qui frappe
la mobilisation
même des gens et personnes
existé et
n'existe
hélas effectivement c'est bien sûr mais
attention
si la personne du moment on se met pas
dans une essentialisation nécessaire les
communistes refusent
l'essentialisation des étiquettes
n'ajuste n'est pas détruite est-ce que
lorsqu'on peut laisser enfermer une
personne dans une une étiquette et
samedi mais bon les morts les sections
des zooms si tu ne fais que j'étais
homosexuel et gbagbo
s'estiment on sait que vous les aimez
mais a comparé nous sommes tous bien
spéciale 2005
nous allons agir au niveau de
l'éducation
une mélodie très
fraîche date 7 jours sur
justement
si
les métiers de séché à son métier et ça
s'est bien
passé
patriat kalisa cette
innovation a contesté qui demeure
attention ne s'exerce pas forcément que
des casques ou d'ailleurs la science po
paris sont à l'étude
mais non cela incombe à châtier les
italiens châtié
pour permettre aux femmes de s'émanciper
à travers un trailer il est 8 à 13
heures mais cela
c'est que les fascinait ça crée des
conditions plus difficiles parce que
paris est
tout
aussi
après tout mais l'ouvrier ses
bas depuis six mois
on
/
sur cette pandémie le
rapport du cor
que le plus
souffert
alors qu'au contraire
à l'international
jusqu'au corps
et bien cassé les conséquences sociales
présent dans 20 pays et quelles mesures
concrètes pourrait
pas se cacher situation catastrophique
j'ai fait des études y est j'ai
mon quotidien le quotidien des étudiants
aussi à ce que disait
j'aime cette
étude
est une chose extrêmement et sa mère ont
fait
sensation inédite qui n'édite
[Musique]
pas vu également des pme tpe
super super
pratique n'est pas qu'il fallait
parfaitement
puis effectivement caissier
qu'est ce qui nous dit fier et très
hospitaliers
les conducteurs
qui
sera notre support des messieurs et qui
ont souffert
[Musique]
et 5 est ce qu'il ya une crise le
capital c'est très bien si tu suis un
père aimant
sous l'inspiration artificiel je me dit
m matic
la facture
en
fait j'ai bien vu ce sont ces machines
et ce sont elles refermées sur le tu vas
nous
mêmes
et rêve ça montera parce que en fait
ils privaient
de la paupérisation et sonorisation
massy
décimée depuis
des années 80 ça simon hébert
incident et je pense que ce genre de
mesure plus
ça va incontestablement déguisée ce
n'est pas une explication très bien nous
sommes pas des masses 400 personnes et
que avait découvert ce jeu obama suivait
un sens social sénat la source
et l entreprise souvent
d'une
location et
s'immisce dit tout ça parce que ça ne
fait que aiguisé les tensions sociales
il a l'air très frais mais vous
commencez à son vaincu les journalistes
mais qu'ils connaissent à dire
ces banques
ne débouchent pas sur une explosion
sociale en mer ce qui s'est passé il ya
pas m'imaginer où j'avais un sujet
universel et toutes les fondations avec
cette mamie 18 mai à soutenir en
210 jours
ça flux mais c'est du
social mais ce serait bien
qu'ils
ne soient pas une situation similaire ce
qui pouvait se répéter mais avoue sperme
et moselle c'est assez
mais creux qui vous
accusent de l'afrique à 65 ans
dans 1 % et 5 % les plus pauvres est
tellement village à l'âge de la retraite
et donc ça se foutant de la laiterie des
mégalithes et de la qualité de vie entre
les plus riches et les plus pauvres et
donc si on fait preuve la nécessité
sociale de 2 d'avancé le de la frette et
même de reculer est-ce que c'est
économique noté m sachant qu'il avait
répliqué de prêter des liquidités plus
vieux de la cedh et de la
sueur de finasser
et
c'est pas
[Musique]
grave
tu travailles à partir du moment où les
industries soeur une
désindustrialisation massive h mar 10 où
[Musique]
les gens simples des chiffres
ce sont ces réalisations passées par la
nationalisation
des grands c'est
l'appropriation des connexions sur la
personnalisation
les énergies lorsque sa mère il se
jette mais son
contribué au massacre absolue du mas
publique nationale énergétique
[Musique]
les énergies les transports mais
la grande distribution
télécommunications tous à tout ce qui
est bon
la collection constate la semaine
c'est la semaine aussi
nous fait part de ces faits des deux
autres est aussi parce que
les usines des industries
des territoires
[Musique]
du territoire
c'est pas parce que tout ça
est avec justement la possibilité de
finir son parti qu'il ait confondu
création michel nadeau les facteurs
relatifs aux tic au
cinéma s'est retourné notre souci est
sacré zoo michel elle doit aussi
financer mes bébés une sécurité sociale
une sécurité simples da peut être beau
à son
salon on joue on s'émeut dirigeants des
branches concis il fallait et c'est
aussi bon
avec après 13h madame sympathisants
d'après ce qu'il soit
58 ans c'est tout à fait le même genre
par une chose
sa trouvaille
celle ci dessus
ce sont aussi des citoyens
quand ils
vivent une
passe là bas
tu es
comme ça
donc c'est une fille cela et sans
capitaine
mais vous savez les institutions
baptiste qui se sera pas aussi où les
semis 400 sa manche on
savait
vous régaler de gilles et je me fais
penser que m
on a dépassé 2 euros le litre d'essence
je tiens à rappeler que les jeunes sont
sortis à allumer bronchiolite comment
vous expliquez que
ne peux que m'en sers pas ne sert plus
je vais dire une
manifestation comme la femme a le droit
d challenge jean jacques roth qui m'a
dit que vous avez très peu comparable à
cet été on savait très peur
qu'est ce qui selon vous pourquoi peux
plus m'en sers plus est ce que ses
collègues qu'on inverse
la douleur que les médecins de l'aider
gilet jaune d'une exane alors c'est que
ce fait
et s'il a du talent menacé par une
chance de l'autre de la macro nos
invités
et voilà c'est une réalité est ce que
c'est ça est-ce que c'est avec le co vie
de ne peut pas été complètement
paralysée
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez est-ce
que
je revends le litre c'est déjà l'élu
c'est ici que j'ai vu comme une chose
mais ma première bd au cinéma
très bas
c'est parce que même limitation de
vitesse placé quatre
départements
et ça ça dépasse mes images mais bon ce
sont
à 7,85 à travers
[Musique]
la figure c'est ça
s'était passé
mais quand on se trompe pas de combat
fonctionnement quotidien
quand il sent la question c'est
incontestablement la vie dans la vie
mais les fragilités de toutes les
organisations
crise mondiale
meetic est
extrêmement
volatil face à qui
si j'étais
qui n'ont qu'une petite bande
deux fédérations de
cheminots ont valu un déclassement des
structures militaires notamment parce
qu'on fera ajouté qu'il existait des
finances mais ce n'est
pas
ça
mais ma fille que 80 considérable
qui existait précédemment parfait les
skis je les joue mais ce qui l'est
du manioc
même si c'est vrai mais les émissions
de résignation et colère une colère qui
semble-t-il est jamais ce médiateur
américain
parce que peu d'éléments ont été sages
il le sait et il me semble plus faible
même effet 10
combinaisons
et je me dis parce que
comme 780 et bourbon sont pleinement
ce qu'on fait mais
ma
chanson
je peux pas lui
qui finit en baisse de 4 mais ça me
bloque fatick
[Musique]
battu très grands palaces crillon dans
les messes en semaine
tous les sens auj
ses contributeurs
cette entrevue il semble obligatoire par
un sujet qui
font pas de vélo demeure la guerre dans
les crèmes du coup le pcf s'est
positionné
je ne trime
faveur du retrait de la liste d'alain
l'otan mais qu'est ce que les positions
de la france concernant ce conflit
d'être boudé notre pays et ça ne leur
assaut des états unis
ont seulement deux secondes places
elle a débuté avec
semences
[Musique]
les années 30
personnes
et damnation
nécessité absolue de progression
quelqu'un avait peur de temps il se
casse une passe magique et compenser
des motos et excellente huile
déclassifiés boucherie de la rue des
chalets les postes
aux états unis pour faire
une crème c'est si beau si
j'ajoute ma part de sybille d'apple il
faut
séparer thème des maîtresses
du désagrément mais peut-être qu'au
match et signer à la même association
ça c'est
gentillet bender
mais je ne dis pas ce que beaucoup
attendaient
ça qu'on n'est pas fan s'utilise on va
plutôt sensible au
fusain cette logique nous sommes
ça ne veut pas
il faut que
les parties
communes la fédération aussi s'est fait
tuer les victimes
si elle me sens en dernier à cette
élection
x
comme des
coucous sylvain reste
sceptique ce sont des états unis et au
brésil
position mais c'est ça le plus paradoxal
fou se sont jamais vides en corée du
nord tout ces gens méritent pas son père
je propose même des produits dérivés de
cette
gamescom
c'est gentil comme un parti qui est
pressenti
le suspens est très clair c'est que tu
es là nous sommes dans une phase
parce que je n'ai vous ce n'est qu'au
long terme soit c'est la soumission à
son
look si son passage détruits en france à
béthune invisible c'est une dissolution
pure et simple est atteint et des
travailleurs
soit 1 cents il n'ya plus possible
du tout senti
[Musique]
aussi ses
concessionnaires
qui on puisse s'opérer après l'appel
étranger proche des stars
n'est pas une musique et ses décorations
sur les baisses soulevé
avec les hui ce n est contré génomique
qui compte c'est g
sociaux notamment pas même pâtir des
analystes mais en tout cas content
régime nous sommes
[Musique]
tous ceux qui
gémissent n'ai pas eu beau mais c'est
une perspective que m c'est marty france
de plus en plus aucune place en séries
comment cela
c
la faim dans cette huitième à trouver
politique
de classe cette économiste et
merci à vous pour
tous les autres